let's continue thinking about partial
derivatives of vector fields
this is one of those things that's
pretty good practice for some important
concepts coming up in multivariable calc
and it's also just good to sit down and
take a complicated thing and kind of
break it down piece by piece so a vector
field like the one that i just showed
is represented by a vector-valued
function and since it's two-dimensional
it'll have some kind of two-dimensional
input
and the output will be a vector
each of whose components is some kind of
function of x and y right so i'll just
write p of x y for that x component
and q
of x y
for that y component and each of these
are just scalar valued functions
it's actually quite common to use p and
q for these values it's one of those
things where sometimes you'll even see a
theorem about vector calculus in terms
of just p and q kind of leaving it
understood to the reader that yeah p and
q always refer to the x and y components
of the output of a vector field
and in this specific case the function
that i chose it's actually the one that
i used in the last video p is equal to x
times y and q is equal to y squared
minus x squared
and in the last video i was talking
about interpreting the partial
derivative of v the vector-valued
function with respect to one of the
variables which has its merits and i
think it's a good way to understand
vector-valued functions in general but
here that's not what i'm going to do
it's actually another useful skill is to
just think in terms of each specific
component so if we just think of p and q
we have four possible partial
derivatives at our disposal here two of
them with respect to p so you can think
about the partial derivative of p with
respect to x or the partial derivative
of p
with respect to y
and then similarly q you could think
about partial derivative of q with
respect to x
x this should be a partial
or the partial derivative of q
with respect to y
so four different values that you could
be looking at and considering and
understanding how they influence the
change of the vector field as a whole
and in this specific example let's let's
actually compute these so derivative of
p with respect to x p is this first
component we're taking the partial of
this with respect to x y looks like a
constant constant times x
derivative is just that constant if we
took the derivative with respect to y
the roles are reversed and this partial
derivative is x because x looks like
that constant
but q
it's partial derivative with respect to
x y looks like a constant negative x
squared goes to negative two x
but then when you're taking it with
respect to y y squared now looks like
a function whose derivative is 2y and
negative x squared looks like the
constant so these are the four possible
partial derivatives but let's actually
see if we can understand how they
influence the function as a whole what
what it means in terms of the picture
that we're looking at up here and in
particular let's focus on a point a
specific point
and
let's do this one here
so it's something that's sitting on the
x-axis so this is where y equals 0 and x
is something positive so this is
probably when x is around 2 ish let's
say
so the value we want to look at is
x y
when x is 2
and y is zero
so if we start plugging that in here
what that would mean this guy goes to
zero
this guy goes to two
this guy negative two times x is going
to be negative two
and then negative two times y
is going to be 0. and let's start by
just looking at
the partial derivative of p with respect
to x so what that means is that we're
looking for how the x component of these
vectors change as you move in the x
direction
so for example around this point we're
kind of thinking of moving in the x
direction vaguely so we want to look at
the two neighboring vectors and consider
what's going on within with the x
direction
but these vectors this one points purely
down this one also points purely down
and so does this one so no change is
happening when it comes to the x
component of these vectors which makes
sense because
the value at that point is zero the
partial derivative of p with respect to
x is zero so we wouldn't expect a change
but on the other hand
on the other hand if we're looking at
partial derivative of p with respect to
y
this should be positive so this should
suggest that the change in the x
component as you move in the y direction
is positive
so we go up here and now we're not
looking at change in the x direction
not looking at change in the x direction
but instead we're wondering what happens
as we move generally upwards so we're
going to kind of compare it to these two
guys and in that case the x component of
this one is a little bit to the left the
one below it it's a little bit to the
left then we get to our main guy here
and it's zero the x component is zero
because it's pointing purely down and up
here is pointing a little bit to the
right so as y increases the x component
of these vectors also increases and
again that makes sense because this
partial derivative is positive this 2
suggests that as you're changing y
the the value of p the x component of
our function should probably keep that
on screen you know the x component of
our vector-valued function is
increasing because that's positive
for contrast let's say we look at the q
component over here so what this is
doing we're looking at changes in the x
and we're wondering what the y value of
the vector does
so we go up here
and now we're not looking at changes in
the y direction
but instead we're going back to
considering what happens as we change x
as we're kind of moving in the
horizontal direction here so again we
look at these neighboring guys
and now the y component starts off small
but negative then gets a little more
negative then gets even more negative
and if we kind of keep looking at these
the y component is getting more and more
and more negative so it's decreasing the
value of q the y component of these
vectors should be decreasing
and that lines up because the partial
derivative here was negative 2. so
that's telling us given that it started
negative it's getting more negative if
it started positive they would have been
kind of getting shorter as vectors as
their y component got smaller and then
finally just to close things off nice
and simply here
if we look at partial of q with respect
to y
so now if we start looking at changes in
the y direction
and we start considering how as you move
below and then starting to go up what
happens to the y component here the y
component is a little bit negative right
it's pointing down and to the left so
down it's a little bit negative here the
y component is also a little bit
negative
over here well it remains a little bit
negative and you know from our heuristic
look there's no discernible change maybe
it's changing a little bit and we don't
have a fine enough vision of these
vectors to see that
but if we actually go back to the
analysis and
uh
see what we computed in fact it is zero
that fact that it looked like there was
not too much change in the y component
of each one of these vectors corresponds
with the fact that the partial
derivative of that y component with
respect to y with respect to vertical
movements is zero
so this kind of analysis should give a
better feel for how we understand the
the four different possible partial
derivatives and what they indicate about
the vector field
and you'll get plenty of chance to
practice that understanding as we learn
about divergence and curl and try to
understand why each one of those
represents the thing that it's supposed
to and and you'll see what i mean by
that in in just a couple videos